s
: : le droit humanitaire;
dede la personne et le droit
dedes réfugiés.
L Les pays ont-ils l'obligation
dede recevoir les réfugiés fuyat
lala guerre (le statut de réfugé
leleur est-il accordé d'emblée)?
- - Lorsque les personnes fuient
unune violence armée, elles
dodoivent être accueillies dans
leles pays limitrophes et recevr
l'l'assistance dont ils ont
bebesoin. Il peut y avoir des
susubtilités qui interviennent,
mamais la règle est inscrite das
leles traités internationaux, on
nene renvoie pas vers un endroit
ouoù des personnes peuvent
crcraindre pour leur vie Ces
pepersonnes si on peut les
acaccueillir sur son territoire.
- - C'est le bon sens qui préva.
LeLes pays de l'union européenne
onont décidé de permettre aux
réréfugiés de séjourner pendant
trtrois ans, de travailler et
d'd'aller à l'école, on s'imagie
quque c'est pas une obligation e
fafaire tout ça, c'est quelque
chchose que l'union européenne t
dédécidé d'offrir?
- - Une convention universelle
pepermet de statuer le statut de
réréfugié, et ces personnes ont
apaprès certains droits.
- - Aux soins médicaux, peut-êt?
- - Aux soins médicaux, etc.
DaDans le cas de cette intégratn
dede d'un État qui fait face à t
afafflux de réfugiés dans les
frfrontières de l'Europe, peut
vovoir que théoriquement les
réréfugiés doivent être accueils
dede la même façon, qu'il a ausi
dede la politique face à ces
memesures qui sont prises. Ça ft
écécho à la crise syrienne, ou n
avavait brillé par la manière dt
onon accueillait les réfugiés.
- - Certains veulent seulement
acaccueillir les réfugiés de
nanationalité ukrainienne, est-e
ququ'ils ont droit?
- - Pour les pays limitrophes,
totoutes les personnes qui fuiet
dodoivent être accueillies sur s
teterritoires où elle trouve
rerefuge.
- - Ça, c'est clair. Parlons
mamaintenant du Canada, qu'est-e
ququ'on fait au Canada? On exige
unun visa, est-ce que c'est
coconforme aux directives?
- - On ne devrait exiger aucun
papapier des personnes qui fuiet
dedes persécutions. L'aspect
paparticulier du Canada, c'est
ququ'il est très loin de ces ea.
PoPour inscrire les demandes qui
ilil va accueillir ou pas sur sn
teterritoire, il a plus de marge
dede manoeuvre que la Pologne oa
RoRoumanie.  Le Canada peut se
dédéployer, je ne sais pas commt
çaça se passe, mais le Canada pt
enenvoyer des fonctionnaires das
leles pays limitrophes et inscre
dedes demandes de personnes qui
vovont vouloir se rendre au
CaCanada.
MaMais toutes les personnes qui
fufuient les persécutions, encoe
unune fois, devrait être accueii
susur les territoires auxquels
elelle pourrait trouver refuge.
- - Qu'est-ce que ça fait, un
cocouloir humanitaire? Comment a
fofonctionne? Est-ce que c'est e
zozone de cessez-le-feu?
CoComment ça fonctionne?
- - Là encore, il faudrait que
j'j'ai lu l'accord. Il est
possible de créer des zones dans
lelesquelles on va sécuriser les
ciciviles ou toutes les personns
ququi sont hors de combat. Il ya
auau moins cinq catégories de
cecette zone qui répond à des
exexigences juridiques différen.
VoVous voyez bien que cette
didifficile pour moi de commentr
dede manière précise sur ses
asaspects la. C'est corridors
huhumanitaires dans le passé ont
paparfois hérité le prétexte de
viviser ennemi et le prétexte de
cocommettre des massacres. Il ft
crcréer des zones sûres pour les
cicivils qui doivent recevoir de
l'l'aide humanitaire.
LeLes personnes hors de combat t
totoujours le droit de recevoire
l'l'assistance humanitaire, c'e-
àà-dire des vivres et des
mémédicaments selon le